only gets to see his land in burka
Village from a distance the 73 year old
hasn't been able to go there for years
although Israeli settlers were evicted
from it 18 years ago they're now
resettling
in March Israeli politicians reversed a
ban on Settlers entering evacuated
settlements in the occupied West Bank
earlier this week settlers set up
Caravans for a religious school in the
evacuated settlement of Hamish
it hurts me to even look at the hill it
takes me hours to get back to normal if
at all this is the land I grew up on
it's very dear and precious to me
vividly remembers when settlers were
evicted in 2005.
the Israeli government pulled settlers
out of all illegal Israeli settlements
in the besieged Gaza Strip as well as
four in the West Bank
it was as if I came back from the dead I
started working on the land planting it
with all kinds of trees almonds Pines
and olives I planted around 800 trees
Palestinians here say the threats they
face from them make it too dangerous to
return When an Israeli Court recently
ruled in their favor
was beaten up for going to his land
the settlers look trained to terrorize
and kill we were injured as the whole
town tried to defend itself against
their attacks
the ocean Beast now has led the trip to
burka and briefed European Union
Diplomat on the recent violations by
Israeli settlers for the settlers
going or they're calling going back to
homish is very important to show that
the settlement project is ongoing or
even renewing and how much is kind of a
symbol despite International pressure
the extreme right-wing Israeli
government is moving forward with plans
to expand settlements for years
Palestinians have watched Israeli
settlers bringing Caravans into their
own lands that soon turn into
settlements they've lost their lands
their resources their freedom of
movement has been limited and that's
increasing their worries about their
future
the occupied West Bank